thrilled honored love this man best at
what he does no two ways about it he'll
be there at the other end of the set
wouldn't want to do this without him
he's mike Mayock how you doing Mike rich
I'm good I still I just don't know how
you handle a full day a radio with all
the energy you have to bring and then go
out and do what we do tonight it's kind
of amazing I only know one speed Mike
but you know that already from the
combine you know that well you know we
know one's real a heater you're a total
classic I that and again just so I
remind me that is a good thing correct
to be a glass yeah it's a really means
you're a tough guy all right I mean
we've seen it all Mike from Tunsil to
all the other craziness what can you
tell me about Josh Allen status going in
tonight from what going into tonight
from what you talked about with Scouts
and evaluators over the last couple of
hours I you know rich I think again is
there a red flag that needs to be
evaluated and checked out yes
do I think many people are panicking
over whether or not that will change his
draft status probably not I think it's
just it's just another part of what our
society has become and unfortunately at
age 15 16 17 you put something out there
that's kind of dumb and immature it
lives forever and the teams will check
it out but I don't think it's gonna
change anything rich so you think that
your mock draft is going to stay as put
that you think the bills are going to
come up and go get Josh Allen well I
mean I think he's in play from number
one on I really do I mean the whole
quarterback thing Ritchie's you know my
draft my mock draft doesn't mean
anything at this point
and we had fun we got a lot of
information out there last I said what I
felt you know I felt like Lee will need
to take Sam Donald for the reasons I
have but I also think Josh Allen's been
in play for Cleveland and John Dorsey
since the combine so despite all the
Baker Mayfield stuff and you know that's
part of the intrigue and I try not to
listen to the noise over like the last
week or two before the draft and there
is a ton of noise out there today
so you would categorize the concept that
Baker Mayfield is a 50/50 choice right
now for John Dorsey and Cleveland if not
the choice you would categorize that his
noise you put that in the noise category
I would tell you that John Dorsey knows
who he's taken and he's known for a
while and there's all kinds of stuff
coming at our building because I want to
hear if anybody was where they want to
trade I don't Baker Mayfield is just as
legitimate a candidate for him as are
the two icing that I've had in my head
for them since the combine meetings
Arnold and Alan so it could go any
direction at number one tonight rich I
mean and John Dorsey doesn't talk to his
wife let alone me or you that's what he
said but I don't believe that that's a
red flag for me Mike I don't believe
that that's noise come on now doesn't
tell his wife that's redundant and I've
known him for a lot of years and I've
talked a lot of that but he knows him to
hold anything about his own situation in
his building and I respect that but I
guess based on his history and who he
has had at quarterback and I know that
Alex Smith is there in his in his time
but I I thought he's like he wants these
big armed drivers of the football and
that's you know I'm a fields got a good
arm but that does not strike me as a
John Dorsey pick that would be to me a
shocker tonight but it would also in my
mind to be the most interesting first
overall choice because that would I
think reconfigure what both New York
teams are thinking about coming in Mike
would you agree with that I would I
think if Mayfield went one it triggers a
whole different conversation it's two
and three and the Giants again and
philosophically you know where I stand
with the diet it doesn't change who they
are philosophically it philosophically
if the quarterback if there's a
quarterback they deemed to be a
franchise quarterback and Eli's air for
the next ten years they have to take
them that trumps everything else and if
darn
that guy and he doesn't go number one
then the Giants could be on the clock on
okay we're not taking Berkeley or job
we're taking the quarterback and then
the Jets are sitting there three going
up there two of them gone now all of a
sudden who is it is it Rosen so if a
field goes one it would be the most
intriguing scenario for our top five
picks of any of the scenarios mike
Mayock here on the Rich Eisen show and
then let's just say I saw I guess you
would say darn old Berkeley going one
two would be the closest version to
chalk that we would have for this year's
draft why do you think the Jets and
again this is your your belief of what
the Jets might do and your thoughts on
the on the evaluation if the Jets have a
Mayfield Josh Rosen decision to make why
do you think they go Baker Mayfield here
I think Mesa was the kind of kid the
kind of personality whether you like
them or not I think he embraces the
moment embraces the big state and there
doesn't excuse me there isn't a bigger
stage then the pressure that's going to
be on the next New York Jets quarterback
and I think this kid relishes that and I
think in the Jets building they've got
to recognize that over what I would call
the uncertainty of Rosen and I don't
even worry about the kids you know you
hear all the stuff about Rosen the kid
when has intelligence been a bad thing
in any endeavor and I don't get that
what I do get is I question his
durability and if I was there at number
three and he had a couple of concussions
last year in the shoulders of you before
and an inability to protect himself in
the pocket I can't take him agree and
then look I mean you have a history of
our the first draft we ever covered
together the video always pops up this
time of year where you look the same and
I've got the flock of seagulls on top of
my lid where we're going down your first
ever mock draft and you nailed Aaron
Rodgers to the Packers at 24 I'd see
that video all the time so you've got a
history of
the knack here and you believe that
again if darn 'old and Berkeley and
Mayfield go and Alan gets acquired by a
trade in the top ten you think Rosen
could drop all the way to 15 at the
Cardinals what you're thinking there I'm
not sure he can get all the way there
but here's my thought process is that if
Denver takes a positional player and
doesn't trade down but takes a
positional player of five which I had
him doing in my mock Quentin Nelson but
starting at six through ten there are no
primary quarterback unless I know that
Indianapolis would love to move back
they've got multiple holes and would
love to acquire additional pick so
that's a logical place for Buffalo to
come up or somebody to come up but six
through ten there's no quarterback needs
Miami at 11 I think there's a
conversation going on in that building
and I think the conversation is kind of
like hey we need a new quarterback on
one side of the building and if I may
Adam GaSe I'm probably looking at them
going you know what you know we're
closer to that 10 and 16 that we worked
as years ago with Tannehill and I
believe I can win with Tannehill I don't
want a quarterback get me the best
position player out there because we can
go compete this year so I did there's a
conversation going on in that building
and if Rosen were to get past or anybody
were to get past 11 the next Waypoint
for the quarterback situation is 15 in
Arizona and Rosen is a gifted game and
he's and he's got a big arm and Steve
time I think time and tournaments down
in that group with love Josh Allen I
think they'd make a move up to go get
Josh Allen if they could but I think
Buffalo's got more draft pick that they
can go up and I don't think teams want
to go all the way back to 15 if they
could not the 12 and then you got Lamar
Jackson to the Ravens I know you have
been raving about Lamar every time I've
done any hits with you on NFL Network in
your previous appearances here on this
show and then off the air too I mean you
have been you have been equally raving
about Lamar Jackson what makes you think
the Ravens would go in this direction
tonight I think a lot of it depends on
what's on their board at 16
I think you're looking at Joe Flacco who
since the Super Bowl win got a big
payday and his production hasn't been
commensurate with the payday after this
season they could trade him or get out
of his contract for very little compared
to where they are today with that
contract and they've got a backup
quarterback rich by the name of Robert
Griffin who could also play the same
offense as Lamar Jackson I look at new
the New Orleans Saints at 27 and it got
jus breezes what 39 years old Sean
Payton is a creative dude and then have
a backup quarterback by the name of
Jason Hill was that a BYU woods man for
and he's running down under kickoff
where I saw that's great and let me tell
you something if they if they could move
up worse Lamar Jackson felt of them at
27 guy like Sean Payton with his
creativity so what I'm trying to do is
connect dots and because Baltimore has
rg3 and because they have pasted some
help
what defensive coordinators say all the
time is a I don't want to face any of
those kind of guys and be the downside
to all that is they're gonna get hurt
sooner or later so you better have two
of them the nice thing last Baltimore
and New Orleans both have two of them do
you have any dots you can connect the
Patriots to him what do you think of
that idea Lamar I don't have it I don't
have the dots but they have the Asian
quarterback obviously and I think don't
Belichick is one of the most outside the
box thinkers in the history of the NFL
so he's got two picks in the first round
and five in the first hundred and I have
absolutely no idea what direction he's
going to go all I would tell you is that
it's pretty obvious looking at his
roster he's got to doughnuts its left
tackle and it back up quarterback slash
heir apparent so I'm fascinated to find
out what direction Bill Belichick go
Mike I love doing this event with you
man
you know the neat thing is we've
basically seen the first three rounds of
the NFL Draft play out just out of order
at the combine I love hanging with you
there
I would never I can't even imagine doing
this event without you it is a personal
and profession
thrill and I just have to ask I've heard
York off in the middle of this you're
feeling alright right you're good we're
good we're good
good my brother okay man so then hang up
don't talk to anybody have some tea with
lemon or whatever and I'll see I'll see
you in a few hours
Yallah fork over it thank you luck man
you're the best brother you're the best
that's mike Mayock the best in the
business
so Rich Eisen show weekdays at noon
eastern on audience